every time you make a choice it places a
mark on your soul
and it makes you what you are
so this is a class about ethics what is
that
the study of human character what one
ought to do
what do we mean by character the
recurrent habits of action
that you follow through in your life
does it mean habits
it's the the steady state of
uh it's formed through habits so you
have the steady state
through which you'll act in a particular
way
because of the kind of character you
have i argue that ethics is the study
of how best to live why is ethics
important
because we're trying to figure out how
to be good
good good is important give me another
definition of that word
juan of ethics yeah
i would say develop development of your
character
character the greek word caressing is it
like a mark
yeah mark h in grave tattoo
you know not paint on the surface dig in
character is dug in
something deep in us it's what stephen
said down there he said
learning how to be good and that is the
whole question
we almost never asked that question
today we
introduce the young to learning
the word education means lead forth
we leave off fourth and that means we
introduce the young to education with an
invitation for them to become whatever
they want to be
but you know they could become ostriches
maybe but they wouldn't be very good at
that
it's the reason ethics is a big subject
it is
the first subject and this is the first
book
ever written about it and i will tell
you back in the paleolithic era when i
was in graduate school
in the first class i had with a great
man he called this
one of the greatest books ever written
so somebody read the first sentence
what does it say
every art and every inquiry and likewise
every action and choice
seems to aim at some good and hence it
has been beautifully said
that the good is that at which all
things aim now
look at the nouns in that sentence
they're all fundamental words what does
art mean technical knowledge
yeah yeah a craft something you made so
you said the word
technical and the greek word is techne
that's
making it means it doesn't mean like in
in the background it's rafael's
school of athens right that's fine art
that's high art but it has in common
with whoever made that glass right there
that it was produced
it was made it was designed and executed
according to skill and with the purpose
in mind
and the first claim is that every time
we do that
we aim at some good that word good we're
going to have to figure out what that
means what's an
inquiry just a question
it's something more than a question
isn't it the word is uh
methodology in greek and a method in
other words
undertake it right it's just you know
heck i wonder what's going to happen
tomorrow and then you go on a bond your
life
that's not an inquiry right we're going
to find out what
ethics is this is an inquiry and also
remember
we're going to encounter in book one
aristotle's saying
the reason this book is to be
read is to become good
this is an urgent inquiry and this
inquiry like
every other he says aims at some good
action what's that word praxis you know
what that means
yeah it's like doing or yeah
we get practice practical from it
practice every time we
act and then the last is choice if you
had to pick
one of these words that word is crucial
because choice is at the center
of the building of character in this
word choice is found
the basis of human freedom
because it's not just that you're free
to choose
it's also that your choices matter very
much
and the claim is every time you make a
choice
it places a mark on your soul and it
makes you what you are
and nobody makes them all perfect
anybody who's determined to make them
well
every day and having failed some
that day start again in the morning
those people become good and we'll find
out
not only good also happy
i'm larry iron president of hillsdale
college you will find if you look at our
online courses that they cover the whole
range
of human learning all the high and
fundamental things
everyone needs to know they are free
because we have always wished
to provide sound learning to anyone who
wishes to have it